Internships are great opportunities
to secure your first job offers.
After I completed my
internship at McKinsey,
I received a full-time offer
to join the Berlin office
as a business analyst.
In the last weeks, many of you asked me
what actually distinguishes an intern
who gets a job offer from
an intern who does not?
This is what we are talking about today,
and I'm going to give you some killer tips
on what you can do to get
your internship right
and to secure your full-time
MBB consulting offer.
My name is Heinrich, and
welcome to another coffee break
with Firm Learning.
If you are a first-time
watcher on this channel,
I try to help you to become
successful in the first years
of your career.
If you're taking any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the Like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and subscribe to my
channel to stay up-to-date
on all my content.
And if you wanna see even more from me,
also follow me on my Instagram.
My handle is @firmlearning.
On my Instagram I'm posting new content
every single day for you.
To start this off, let's
briefly talk about my story.
What did I do?
When I was a young
student at the end of my
undergraduate Bachelor degree,
I did an internship with
McKinsey in the Munich office.
And after the internship,
I received a job offer
to join McKinsey full-time
as a business analyst.
And I know that this is
not specific to McKinsey,
but if you look into other MBB firms,
such as BCG or Bain,
similar things are possible,
as is with some of the investment banks.
Internships, they offer a
great, amazing opportunity,
not only to collect some work experience
and to polish your CVs,
but also to actually
receive a chance to secure a job offer
that you can directly use
then, after university studies.
And I need to tell you that
I'm really proud of you guys
in the Firm Learning community.
Because I did a survey
on my Instagram account,
and I asked you how many of you already
received a job offer after internship?
And indeed, more than 40% of you
told me that yes, you already received
a job offer after internship.
I believe this is a very high quota,
and for sure, significantly above average.
So you already know what
grade of an opportunity
internship can be, and
to all of those of you
who haven't received such an offer yet,
please take this as an inspiration.
This is possible, and I hope
that my tips can help you
to turn your consulting
internship into a job offer,
and therefore into a
great success for you.
In this video, I'm going
to give you crucial tips
on three areas, and what you can do
to secure your job offer
after an internship.
And the key takeaway is that as an intern,
you're basically
evaluated against the role
of a full-time consultant.
So the people you work
with will ask themselves,
"If I would hire this guy,
"could he be a successful
consultant today?"
So in order to understand
what you need to do
in order to receive such an offer,
you need to understand how
consultants are evaluated,
how their performance is measured.
And while, of course,
every single consultancy
has its own evaluation
scheme, which differs a bit
in the language and the
terms that are being used,
in the end, it comes
down to three dimensions
that pretty much all consulting firms use
to evaluate their
consulting level employees.
The first is your analytical skills.
So how good are your
intellectual capabilities?
How good are you at Excel?
How well are you to perform an analysis,
and what do you contribute
in problem-solving sessions?
The second are your
skills with the client.
So how do you interact with the client?
Does the client take you seriously?
Are you able to lead meetings?
Just to interact with the client well,
and be perceived by the client
as a competent business professional.
And the third dimension
are your team skills.
So are you a team player?
Can you interact and
cooperate with the team well?
Are you bringing value
to how the team operates,
and are you really making
a positive contribution
to solving the problems
that the team has at hand?
The first skill that
you need to demonstrate
as an intern are your analytical skills.
In many consulting internships,
one of the first tasks that you will get
are some little analytical tasks.
Your project lead might
give you a data set,
some Excel files, and
will ask you to conduct
a couple of analyses, maybe
to build a small model,
that is in some way related to the work
that they team is doing.
Here the very first tip I have for you
is to just be extremely
diligent in your work.
There are some junior colleagues,
that if you give them a certain
piece of work, you just know
that there will be some errors in it.
Some junior colleagues tend to hand in
a certain piece of work,
well-knowing that this is not ready yet.
That the project lead, or somebody else,
will still need to work with them
to look into it and to fix it.
And this is a very bad attitude.
You shouldn't walk around as an intern
with a mindset that
somebody else will still
check my work, that somebody else will fix
all the last errors that I didn't catch.
You should make sure that your work
is client-ready from the get-go.
And one of the little tips and tricks
that I learned at McKinsey
early on from a project lead
is that you should always
ask yourself the question,
whenever you submit a piece of work,
"Is this ready to be sent
to a board-level member
"of my client?"
So would you be comfortable
sending your piece of work
directly to a C-Level member
of your client organization,
with your name under it?
Would you be comfortable with that?
And if you would not be
comfortable with that,
then probably your work isn't done yet.
Then probably you are not there,
where you really should be.
Do the double-checks,
do the triple-checks.
Make sure that your work is error-free,
that there are no bugs in your Excel model
that all the formulas
are set up correctly,
and only then submit it
to your project leader
as your final piece of work.
The second is how good you
are with the technical skills
that you will need in your
daily consulting life.
And in MBB consulting, this
comes down to using Excel
and using PowerPoint as
the two technical tools
most frequently used.
And of course, not all
interns are business graduates
who have already extensive
knowledge in using these tools.
Even with a liberal arts
degree, you can intern
with MBB, so McKinsey, BCG, or Bain.
And of course, people will
be highly understanding
that in the beginning,
maybe your Excel skills
aren't very well, because you didn't work
with Excel that much in the past.
But what people will
expect is that you pick up
these skills quickly.
Because the reality is
if you are bad at Excel,
and if you're bad at PowerPoint,
then especially in the junior
consultant level tasks,
you aren't much of a help to the team.
So my advice here would
be that if you struggle
with Excel or PowerPoint,
make sure that you pick up the skill.
Maybe even invest your
weekends checking out
some other YouTube videos
or some online courses
to make sure that you build
the skill set quickly,
because it just is an important
skill set of a consultant.
And of course, if you
have not seen it yet,
I have a whole playlist on this channel
on how to create consulting-style management presentations.
I will link the playlist
here somewhere above me
for you to check it out.
Have a look, I believe it's
really worthwhile your time.
And if you're really
serious to build these
consulting-level PowerPoint
presentation skills,
I even built a multi-hour course,
teaching you everything that is required
to build PowerPoint
presentations in the style
of MBB consulting firms.
I have already over 10,000 students
taking the course, with lots of reviews.
If you're interested, check out the link
to the course below in the description.
Have a look through the reviews,
whether this might be something
that might add value to you as well.
Regarding your analytical skills,
the last tip and advice
that I wanna give you
how you can portray, how you
can show your analytical skills
is yet your participation
in problem solving sessions.
So what is a problem solving session?
In MBB consulting firms,
frequently you will
come together with your team,
with your project lead,
maybe with other associates
on the team, often also partners joining.
And then you discuss
the important problems
that you are currently trying to solve.
And via the team discussion,
and via everybody's contribution,
you try to come up with
the best possible solution
for a problem that you are facing.
And this is now your opportunity to shine,
because these are now
team internal meetings.
If you have a good idea,
if you have a good contribution to make,
don't be shy, and let the team
participate on your thoughts.
Because more often than not,
you might have a good idea
on how to move forward
a certain aspect.
And this is especially true
if you have been actually
working on a specific topic
in the last days or week,
because then very likely,
nobody on your team
will have more in-depth
knowledge of all the numbers,
of all the data that you've
been crunching than yourself.
So don't be shy, share your thoughts.
Especially if it's an
internal team meeting,
where the risk of saying something
which might be perceived in
a negative way by a client
is very low.
The second key dimension
that you are going to be
evaluated against are your client skills.
And this basically comes
down to how you interact
with the clients, and of
course, also, how the clients
perceive you as a consultant.
So how does your project lead,
how do your other team members evaluate
whether you have proper client skills?
And the main question that
they will be asking themselves
when they observe you
interacting with clients
is whether they can bring you to a client,
whether they can trust
you to spend your time
at a client without any
of them being there.
So what this comes down to
is that you would now, of
course, wanna make sure
that in client meetings
you show that you can have
a positive contribution,
that the client does
take you seriously, and of course,
that you're not somebody
who would say things
which would hurt the client relationship,
or are unprofessional in any other way.
And what I would recommend you here,
especially in the first days or weeks,
if you're a bit unsure whether
you should say something
in a specific instance,
it's usually better
to say rather too little,
than to say too much.
As an intern, the people understand
if you maybe talk a bit
less than other colleagues
in client meetings, and actually
would be rather surprising
if in a client meeting,
you as an intern would take
the more dominant role
in the conversation.
So while, of course,
you should try to avoid
to come across as shy or insecure,
usually saying a bit too little
is better than saying too much.
The reason is that
especially as an intern,
and maybe you didn't have that much
of work experience before consulting,
it is sometimes hard to
assess whether a certain thing
that maybe crosses your mind
in that specific instance
is now really appropriate
and helpful for the meeting.
But of course, sitting in
all these client meetings
and saying nothing all the time
is not a good strategy.
'Cause you need to show
some client skills.
You need to show that
you are able to interact
in a helpful way with clients.
And I already created a whole video
about how you as a junior colleague
can really add value to meetings,
even if you're not the most senior person
in the meeting.
So I highly encourage you
to check out the video.
I will link it somewhere above here.
There are many great tips in this video.
Just one thing that I
wanna mention right here
is that what you can
always do also as an intern
to be the number guy.
So as an intern, after some days or weeks,
you will likely have received some kind
of analysis package that
you have been working on,
maybe some Excel data sheets
that you have been analyzing.
So now you are an expert on
this specific piece of data
on this specific package of analysis
that you were asked to work on.
So whenever the discussion touches
this subject field that
you've been working on,
make sure that you are really
the expert on that field.
So in the meeting, maybe
have your laptop with you,
have all the data with you,
so if there's any question on some number,
make sure that you are able to
pull the number out quickly,
that you can directly tell
the reliable solution.
And this will help you to come across as
a relevant and competent
member of the consulting team
towards the client.
But this will also help your project lead,
because he now builds the confidence.
He now builds the trust in you,
that you have all your numbers in order,
that you have the big
picture of all the things
that you're doing, and
whenever he's with you,
he can trust you to know all the things
that you have been working on in detail.
And this now also helps your project lead,
because now your project
lead doesn't need to prepare
all these things to
that level of detail now
for all the future meetings.
And in the second area, how
you control your client skills
is especially after you
are a couple of more weeks
into the internship is
now to take the lead
for certain sections of client meetings.
So of course, there are different
types of client meetings,
different types of interactions.
But often, several topics are covered
in these client meetings.
So after some time that
you feel confident enough,
suggest to your project lead
that now you will take the lead
for the parts of the meeting that cover
the specific work that
you have been working on.
And often, after some time,
the project lead will
actually suggest this
to yourself as well.
So show him that you're ready for that,
that you're willing and
able to take the lead,
leading your client through
some contents that you prepared,
or anything similar to that.
So to sum up, make sure
that you show your team
that they can trust you with clients,
that you can interact
well with the clients.
And especially in the beginning,
if you're a bit in doubt,
probably rather don't say
something than say something.
But then after some time,
try to actively take the lead.
Look out for these opportunities
where you can show your team
that you interact well with clients.
Take the lead on some presentations.
Take the lead, at least on
parts of some client meetings.
If you present certain
sections of a presentation,
and if you do all of this well,
then for sure you will tick all the boxes
for the evaluation of an intern.
The third key skill area
where you need to show your
competence as an intern
to secure your full-time
offer is team skills.
Here you will be evaluated how
you interact with the team,
whether you are a team player or not,
whether you are somebody who
is slowing the team down,
or whether you're somebody who
makes a positive contribution
towards the team atmosphere,
towards the positive,
collaborative nature in the team room.
And this is so important,
because in consulting,
you will spend so much
time with your colleagues.
You will sit in one team
room for days and days,
often even until late in the evening.
And you just do not want to work together
with people who are annoying,
who have negative vibe,
who are not contributing
anything to make all of this
a great experience.
Of course, the more senior
you get as a consultant,
the more you will be evaluated against
how well you are to mentor
more junior colleagues,
how well you coach more junior colleagues,
all of this is, of course, a
bit difficult as an intern,
because you are literally
the most junior colleague out there.
So what can you do?
How can you make an impact on your team?
The first suggestion I
have is to really avoid
sending too many negative
vibes and complaints.
Of course, it's completely okay
to have some banter with your
colleagues in the evenings,
and if there's anything that's going on
that really makes you uncomfortable,
of course you should say that,
and you should be encouraged to say that.
What you should avoid is to be somebody
who just complains all the
time about all kinds of things.
Don't spread negative vibes
to the team all the time.
This is just draining energy.
Yes, sometimes working in
consulting can be tough.
Sometimes the days go on for much longer
than many of your teammates
will have hoped for,
but it really doesn't help to
talk about it all the time,
to always mention how bad and
annoying the situation is.
Instead, whenever possible,
try to make a positive contribution.
Spread positivity,
motivate your colleagues.
Just contribute to a positive
atmosphere in the team room.
This is just so important,
and I just cannot stress it enough,
also as having been a project lead,
how difficult it is to
work with colleagues
who just have this constantly
negative vibe around them.
The second suggestion that I have for you
in order for you to
portray your team skills
is to just be observant.
Observe your colleagues.
And sometimes it will happen
that your whole team is quiet
in a crunch, and as an
intern, maybe you feel
like that in this specific moment,
you just cannot contribute
that much to the work.
And in these situations, ask yourself,
what could be other things
that you can do right now
to help your team?
And these are often some little things.
So what about you tidy up,
you clean up your team room?
Because maybe it's getting late,
and your whole team is in a crunch
to finish off this last
piece of work that they need
to send out in order for
them to call it a day.
And then what's really annoying is that
if then you still need
to clean up and tidy up
the team room before you can go.
So if you as an intern,
maybe have a bit more slack,
maybe don't have that many things to do,
then just be comfortable to take up
this kind of work as well.
And just tidy up the team room.
Make sure that you get
everything ready for the team
to leave whenever they are finished.
On a similar situation, if
you feel that the whole team
is in a crunch, and maybe
you have a bit more time,
then why don't you take the responsibility
to order food for the team?
Or maybe you get a
coffee from the cafeteria
for the team?
So of course, as an intern,
it is not your prime job
to get the coffee, to
order the food, and so on.
And you will experience
it frequently enough
that your teammates will do
these same things for you.
But these are just the little things
that will be appreciated.
People will notice that.
And these are also
things that will let them
perceive you as a team player,
as somebody who adds to
the whole team dynamic.
And this is always a great opportunity.
And the last suggestion that I have
is to organize team events.
Of course, this depends always a bit
on the culture of the consulting firm.
But at least in MBB consulting,
it's quite common that every month or so,
the team goes out in the
evening for a team event.
And these can be all kinds of things.
So when I was a consultant,
we visited escape rooms.
We went to some sport events.
We had a wine tasting.
We had an event together
with some artists,
drawing, paintings, whatever you feel like
could be fun for the whole team
might be fair game for such a team event.
And often the project lead
asks for a consultant who
can organize the event
for the whole team.
And this, of course, from my perspective,
would be a perfect opportunity
for an intern to shine.
By organizing a team event,
you can show your organizational skills,
and just contribute to the
whole team having a good time.
But of course, if you
do that, then make sure
that you can get it right,
that you can organize this
in a smooth way that really
helps the whole team.
So to sum up, to show your team skills,
make sure that you're a team player,
that you spread positive vibes,
that you help your team also
on minor tasks if required,
and hey, why not organizing a team event,
if there's a good opportunity for that?
So to sum up, the three
most important skill areas
that you will be evaluated against
is your analytical skills,
your client skills,
and your team skills.
So make sure that during your internship,
you show that you can perform well
against all these dimensions.
Now, of course, I'd be super
interested to hear from you.
What were your experiences
in your internships?
Were you already able
to secure a job offer
after an internship?
What were the tips and
strategies that you used?
I'd highly appreciate it if
you share your strategies
and insights here in the
comments section below,
so that other viewers of
this video can benefit
from that as well.
And if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to my channel.
And please also turn on
the notification bell,
because otherwise it might be that YouTube
is not showing you new videos from me,
even though you already
subscribed to my channel.
And again, if you want
to see even more from me,
also follow me on my Instagram.
My handle is @firmlearning.
Thanks to all of you for watching.
I really appreciate your time.
This was Heinrich from Firm Learning.
Have a good day!